she can't see coming because everybody's
talking about her movie burbot
did you see the numbers more than 45
million Netflix subscribers watch the
movie that's a record for the streaming
service but people are doing more than
just watching the movie yourself it's
all about meme worthy moments to avoid
an unknown entity that causes people to
kill themselves when they see it
Sandra's character and her kids Don
blindfold and run cue this hilarious
synopsis in real life bullets gone full
mom beast mode before I try really hard
not to go there with my kids but you do
that when you're scared
comparing scenes to the Kardashians
polarized viewers have kept it trending
on Twitter for five days now Kim herself
posted watching bird box I really like
it who has seen it Chrissy Teigen 'he's
response kimberly like everyone in the
entire world many took the social media
poking fun at everything from how the
wind signifies danger
to how birds sense trouble ahead Netflix
is totally in on the joke posting video
of real birds reacting ironically when
bullet needed a baby belly to play her
pregnant character Sandra had it filled
with birdseed and on set she and co-star
Avante Rhodes told me those blindfolds
were trouble how much stuff did you hit
is this the person who ran into
everything good person know I'd know it
let's let's this clarify we had an
amazing Steadicam operator who knew how
to move the camera away but I would
switch directions a little piece of
metal that's off the the lens hit them
twice which are my fault the third time
was not my fault but there was an injury
I will say that she fell and got injured
oh I just want and by the way there is
more did you see this it's a new viral
sensation called
the bird box challenge well people try
to do everyday stuff while blindfolded
yes of which of course profit net flix
the issue this warning can't believe I
have to say this but please do not hurt
yourself
with this bird box challenge your kids
right now I'm probably running or I want
to send them around the house with the
bird go get my shoes yes
[Music]